dis dans ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre elle porte
sur l'avenir que vous avez le pouvoir de
réserver ou 240 salariés de l'entreprise
arjowiggins security dont la liquidation
judiciaire a été brutalement annoncé mi
janvier des familles bouleversées des
vies sans lendemain ce sont 250 millions
d'argent public distribué par la bpi à
des fonds voyous qui se sont comportés
comme des charognards
arjowiggins et le coeur battant de tout
un territoire en seine-et-marne le nôtre
un savoir faire exceptionnel pour
fabriquer le papier sécurisé français
pour nos passeports cartes d'identité
cartes grises permis de conduire
aujourd'hui la seule en france à ce jour
nous en sommes réduits à mendier auprès
de la ministre du travail pour obtenir
un pays saut digne pour les salariés
je suis sénatrice de seine-et-marne et
je veux faire part à la haute assemblée
de mon indignation face à votre mutisme
j'ai écrit au président de la république
pour l'alerter sur l'extrême urgence à
intervenir
pas de réponse je vous en ai adressé une
copie ainsi qu'à bruno le maire pas de
réponse hier christian jacob vous a posé
une question pas de réaction ou si peu
que faut-il faire pour attirer votre
attention
il serait inconcevable que la france ne
fabrique pas elle-même son papier
sécurisé pour ces documents officiels
c'est en france qu'il faut le faire et
pas ailleurs
qui d'autre car joe higgins pour le
faire c'est non seulement une question
d'ambition de stratégie mais aussi de
sécurité nationale qu'attendez vous
monsieur le ministre pour mobiliser un
financement pour aider ses salariés
remarquable investi et responsable a
créé une société coopérative et
participative
qu'attendez vous pour vous déplacer sur
le terrain
ces salariés se désespère d'obtenir
votre aide concrète et nous aussi
pour vous répondre
paroles tout secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'action des comptes publics
sur iphone merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice vous appeler
l'attention du gouvernement sur la
situation de la société un visioguide
security de juillet sur morin qui a été
placé comme l'ensemble des sociétés du
groupe arjowiggins en liquidation
judiciaire le 30 janvier dernier
vous l'avez rappelé cette ancienne
filiale du groupe papetier sequana la
société arjowiggins security qui emploie
265 salariés dont environ 220 sur le
site de production vous citez avait été
c'était en avril
ces départs dont en avril 2018 par
sequana au groupe bluemotion
technologies détenues par le fond
germano-suisse parter capital group
dans ce cadre le repreneur s'était
engagé devant le tribunal à limiter les
suppressions d'emplois et à soutenir
cette société dans ses efforts de
modernisation et de recherche de
nouveaux marchés
il s'était également engagé à subvenir
au financement des opérations par le
biais de divers instruments bancaires
notamment des garanties de 7 millions
d'euros qui devait être trouvé quelques
mois à peine après la reprise le groupe
bmt n'avait proposé aucun plan
industriel crédible et a toujours refusé
d'octroyer le moindre euro pour remédier
à une situation financière très dégradée
malgré les nombreux efforts faits par
l'état vous avez rappelé y compris
financièrement et l'attitude
constructive des salariés qu'il faut
saluer car ils se sont montrés
systématiquement ouvert pour améliorer
la compétitivité du site
la déclaration de liquidation judiciaire
confirme l'échec du groupe b mt et
l'irresponsabilité responsabilité des
dirigeants du fonds par terre vous avez
souligné madame la sénatrice combien
cette usine avec une production
importante notamment pour la production
de papier sécurisé monsieur le premier
ministre a eu l'occasion de répondre
hier au président jacob qui posait une
question sur le même sujet vous l'avez
aussi rappelé monsieur le premier
ministre a rappelé à la fois
l'engagement d'états l'engagement total
de l'état pour trouver des solutions
mais il a aussi dit et souligné devant
l'assemblée nationale comme je me
permets de le faire devant le sénat le
caractère extrêmement dégradée de la
situation vous connaissez ce site vous
connaissez la situation financière nous
pouvons ensemble pointé les
responsabilités de tel ou tel acteur
économique et privés qui ne tient pas
les engagements qui avaient été pris et
les risques que cela fait peser sur ce
secteur-là
il faut regarder cette réalité en face
travailler ensemble hier la question
posée par le président jacob augurer
d'une vraie capacité des élus à se
rassembler avec le gouvernement pour
chercher ensemble toutes les solutions
possibles
j'ai assez de faire du vent aujourd'hui
pour votre majorité la question n'est
pas de savoir si on doit cocher la case
parents ou parents de à la place de père
et mère mais de sauver des emplois qui
assureront une indépendance à la france